hello everyone and welcome to more fun
from the 2009 FIBA World Cup it's a
shocker mama Diarra vs. team or the job
of we don't we don't often show games by
Rajah Boaz somehow we don't show games
from tournaments where he is playing but
here is a one such event where we get to
see him in action
so mommy Tara versus at a job of two of
the classical games between the two of
them have been drawn then the two rapid
games have also been wrong
the third rapid game that's the rapid
game with the shorter time control has
been run and this is game number 4 so
mama Diaw gets the white pieces in the
fourth rapid game if this is also wrong
then we go into the boot section so
without further ado let's check it out
it's really an awesome game the four by
Mahmoud er we have Knight to f6 c4
that's a Bishop c4 e6 Knight to c3 and
d5 of course the Queen's gonna be the
client is on the board with seek after
Sundy 5e capture son b5 and now Bishop
to g5 Bishop to e7 preparing to Castle
and III white continues development with
castles and Bishop to d3 so all very
standard stuff
we have c6 and now quinta c2 is the most
popular move here but mom gr goes for
the less popular one Knight G 2 we have
Knight B to d7 and now Queen to c2
putting pressure on the h7 pawn but it's
not a problem as the Knights are keeping
an eye on that point with rook to e8 and
now mama D our of castles and the now
tonight to f8 the knight will now come
to east 6 so he can further harass the
bishop on g5 with f3 preparing to strike
in the center and now g6 by our job of
Bush up to h4
well expecting Knights the e6 and the
Mamedov goes nice to e6 and here mom
Europe knows this position very well as
he already held himself against
Circassian in 2016 the game ended in a
draw in the game rook 81 was played but
here mama D our switches the King to h1
with b5 my mama D of preparing that
should be 7 he also wants to expand on
the Queen side and get the a rock into
the game and here a3 is a known
that has been played in this position
but Brooke a to c1 is a new move by
Mahmoud Arif so as I move 14 we have a
completely new game Mahmoud Iago's
better to b7 he develops the light
square bishop and now Knight to d1 with
rook to c8 bringing the rook into the
game and now the Queen doesn't like
being in the same file as the rooks Oh
Queen to d2 and now a6 strengthening the
chain on the Queen side and here we have
b4 so just a nice a lock on the c5
square preventing black from ever
pushing it might come useful in the
future and here mummy a Rajah bow goes
for Knight to e4 this exchange is well
possible because the bishop on h4 is
unguarded and here mama Darrell doesn't
like F captures on e4 seems like a nice
idea if captures Bishop captures and
then e v just your bishop again has his
open file as an i semi open a file for
the rook and no problems there mama
prefers the other line he prefers Bishop
captures on e4 Bishop captures and now
bringing the bishop backs ok this keeps
your pawn chain intact but I don't know
seems like this pawn being on e5 would
the semi open file for the rook that
does have you know its merits but I'm
sure mom Yard has his reasons for
preferring this one and okay 'if I've a
job of strikes on the Queen side and now
a 3 with a capture some be for a capture
some be for and now Queen to e7
connecting rooks and putting pressure on
the B 4.4 now the Queen is stuck
defending it and f4 form a media of
creating a nice outpost on e5 for his
knight now mama Diarra wants to get this
night over to G 1 2 F 3 ends the e5
where it will be a monster night with
Knight the f8 our job of is preparing to
bring his knight over to b6 where from
where it can come not there but the c4
which will also be an excellent square
for his Knight so nice the g1 the search
for the perfect outpost for the night
begins with 937 nice to f3 I'm going for
a 5 best back to f6 and then out comes
Knight to e5 so this is now an excellent
night
you don't really gain anything by
capturing there this probably
what my media had in mind when he
preferred this line over to that one now
if the night even is captured then of
course this will this point will capture
an e5 and we'll we will get the same
structure for example it was the same if
this pawn captures an e4 and you push it
to e5 or f4 and then you capture on e5
but a job of not interested in such such
a trade he was night to be six prepares
Knight to c4 and now Knight the b2
Mammadov is awaiting for Knight to c4
now we have Knights the c-4 with Knight
capture son b4 and c4 b captures on c4
and now after this trade raja baath has
a very nice path pawn on c4 with E for
by mamedyarov
bishop back to g7 probably leaving the
opportunity to to maybe push f6 to get
rid of the knife from e5 so rook ce-1
now putting the rook on this a very nice
file Queen to c7 and now h4 h4 preparing
h5 and f5 to bust open the Kings side
with Bishop to e6 preparing to win
material with c3 if c3 then the Queen
and the rook around her attack so look
to have to not allowing this discovery
and now look to b8 the idea is the
before ponies now under attack and the
Queen will return to d6 to put more
pressure on the b4 pawn mama drf
continues his attack on the King side
with h5 and now Queen to d6 just going
after the b4 pawn and here mama dar
plays Queen to d1 he abandons the
defense of the b4 pawn and his idea is
well if the point is grabbed for example
rook captures and before you will get e
capture son d5c captures and now f5 with
this very nice pressure on the King side
and even if Bishop captures an e5 you're
gonna get H captures on g6 so starting a
very nice attack and now after captures
captures you can capture D captures on
e5 and all of the traits here captures
captures captures Queen f1 it's well it
seems like a very ugly position for
black and black is in fact winning in
this position according to the engine
but when you're playing a rapid game you
don't have that much time to calculate
it's
easy to get discouraged for going into
such a such such a long variation of
course and especially when mama yard is
offering it so first a job of goes D
captures an e4 with the shop captures on
e4 and now only now rope captures and
before but now mama Dara plays a very
interesting move he plays Knight
captures and f7 yes the thumbnail move
and well the engines will tell you that
it's not a very good move but the
engines don't know that a move is well
better or worse depending on the time
format of the game for example in a
classical game
this wouldn't be a great move but for a
rapid game this is an excellent move as
now you have to react your queen is
under attack you just lost the f7 pawn
there is no better better move than to
capture the knight so or a job of
capture it and only now f5 by Mahmoud
yarv
so here the the best defense is just
giving up the the rook for the bishop
here because White's already sacrificed
one piece for example captures captures
and then you just go back sorry not that
captures here first white will play F
captors and g6 would check you have to
allow this and after King moves you will
recapture here and then the game
continues this is the best for black but
the job of tries a different line he
plays a Bishop to f6 he wants the cut
off the rocks influence on the F file so
mami job just grabs it with F captures
and g6 with check King to g7 and here
believe it or not
mama D ARBs Knight sacrifice pays off
here in this position my major is
winning but it's not an easy move feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for Mama dr f in this
position well i give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on being an
excellent pusher of pawns and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the idea is h6 with check and well it's
just the game over here for example any
of these moves lose the game for example
if king to f8 you're gonna get the g7
checked and now after king t7 you get a
discovery burst of capture sun sea sex
with check your king has to move now
you're gonna capture here with checking
to see seven you're gonna bring a queen
into the game
of course the game is over so after h6
check a king to f8 is no good King to g8
on the other hand you will get Bishop to
d5 check and you just well it's check
and the once the bishop is captured you
will pick up the rook here and that's
game over and of course if you go King
to h8 it's not much better you will just
get rook captures on f6 attacking the
Queen Queen captures and now g7 check
King g8 and now the same idea above d5
check you will capture it now you get
rook captures here with Czech king f7
and now just point the g8 Queen is mate
so after h6 you're only good option is
to actually capture the pawn and only
now you play G captures on h7 that's the
point and now that's the king is wide
open here there is a very little black
can do for example if you play something
like Queen captures and before you get
Queen to g4 with the threat of Queen g6
mate and if you eliminate the threat for
example rookie actress here now you get
a rout captures on f6 Czech Queen
captures on f6 and now rook captures on
e4 while still having to keep an eye on
the h7 point for example Ruby 1 check
King H - you're gonna capture on h7
but now Queen d7 check and here you are
just lost if you go out the board you're
getting rook rook to e8 if you go down
the board then rook the e6 just picks up
the Queen so after King g7 h6 a
beautiful winning move but mom in Europe
doesn't find that mommy there are first
place G captors on h7 probably preparing
h6 on the next move but are a job of
beats him to it he plays a queen to g3
now preventing Queen to g4 also putting
pressure on the rock on f2 so look the
f3 by mommy they are attacking the Queen
and now Queen to h4 with Czech mommy
your block shut we have roped the h3 but
now pause the video once again and try
to find the winning move for a job of in
this position while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent giver of Queens and for those
of you who just won't enjoy the show
rook captures on e4 and
you don't really have much to do here if
you capture the Queen then it's the very
straightforward route captures on h4
check King has to move and now Bishop
captures on d4 check and if you don't
want to part with your queen
you will go King to f1 but now c3
another discovered to check and for
example if you play a rookie - or
something you just get rook to h1 and
this is now mate as the bishop covers f2
so you don't really gain anything by
grabbing the Queen here Mamedov try to
look to f1 but he just lost lost a piece
on e4 and now rook to be three eligible
again forces him to take the Queen you
cannot capture the rook for example as
it spins so here momager has to capture
the Queen rook captures on h4 with rook
captures an h4 with check King g1 and
now again Bishop captures on d4 mama D
our of blocks with rook to f2 but it
doesn't help here just rook the B to the
roof will be picked up on the next move
and it was in this position and move 44
that shot your mum resigned the game and
with this resignation he is out of the
video World Cup now where Java has been
an elite player for many many years but
somehow in this matchup
I really thought mama Dara would win so
this really caught me by surprise but
you know things always always happen in
chests so there's nothing to do here
there are no tricks there are no checks
you can't capture here g4 also covered
by the rope so you can't even try to go
for some perpetual ideas next move
you're just gonna capture the rook and
that's it there's there's nothing to be
done here
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it if you missed the standings in the
previous two videos here are the
standings just dingo face alexandra gory
shook
nikita veto will face you Angie Jeffrey
Xian will face team or the job of and
the max impartial agreable face level
Oregon will be very interesting like I
said in the previous video as Ireland
and England
I wonder spot in the candidates through
the 2017 video World Cup it will be very
interesting to see if they can repeat
their success here will not be easy but
you know will be very interesting so
once again I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like
I think such a hurry Robin we're
Gianluca Santa Rosa Aquila to glory
Antonin Guin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World Cup
and checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day